ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้สวัสดีค่ะนะพี่
เอี้ยงครับผมโอเคอ้าวกลับมาเจอกันอีกแล้ว
กลับมาเจอกับน้องอาร์ตี้กับครูพี่เอ๋ใน
ช่องกล้องเลนส์เซิลไทยอยู่ด้านไหนด้านนี้
อันนี้อันไหน OK ข้างบนข้างบนอยู่ข้างบน
ครับค่ะอ่ะครูอ่ะตีเค้านี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันจันทร์ครับ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ลั่นครับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
อาจารย์ที่ 21 ครับวันที่ 21 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคมครับเดือนนี้เป็นมีนาคมใช่ขอ
เท่าไหร่คะมีผช
2565 ครับปีคศเท่าไหร่คะมีคศ 2000  22
ครับปีนี้อ่ะ
เออแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลาอ่า
9:00 น 25 น.ครับสามช่วงที่ 3 ทุ่มยี่
สิบห้านาที
ครูโยตี้อาบน้ำ 19:00 นเป็นเวลาพักผ่อน
เนาะอ้าวมาดูทีวี
นอนที่เฮ้ย
ดูหนังดูวีดีโอราคาๆครับวันนี้ครู Arty
มีเรื่องของหนัง r
ดูนักเรียนฟังไหมคะอ่ะทรายครับวันนี้มี
หนังให้นักเรียนฟังก่อนนอนก่อนที่จะไปนอน
ว่าดูหนังก่อนมาฟังครัวตี้เล่าหนังให้ฟัง
นะครับเล่าให้ครูฟังด้วยนะคะให้ครับได้
ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวฟังกับครูเอ๋ดูพร้อมกันนะคะ
แต่ว่าหนังเรื่องนี้ครูเอ๋เคยดูไหมไม่รู้
เลยไหมชื่อเรื่องอะไรคะค่ะหนังเรื่องนี้
ใช่ไหมครับเอ่อภาษาอังกฤษชื่อเรียกเรื่อง
presents วิวแต่ภาษาไทยภาษาไทยชื่อยาว
มากชื่อยาวมากอยู่นะครัวตี้ขอดูชื่อภาษา
ไทยก่อนภาษาไทยชื่อเออ
เมืองรีโมทคนทะลุมิติมหัศจรรย์ยังเอาไว้
เบื้องรีโมทเมืองรีโมทคนทะลุมิติ
มหัศจรรย์
ขอ
เมือง
รีโมท
หาใช่เขาเป็นรีโมทแบบนี้แต่เป็นรีโมททีวี
รีโมททีวีรีโมทอะไรนะคนทะลุมิติ
ทะลุมิติก็คือมีมาให้กูไอ้ดาวก่อนนะมิติน
และก็คือของเรานั้นก็ต้องทะลุไปอีกมิติ
หนึ่งทรายเงาตาเป็นมิติที่อยู่ในในทีวี
แสดงว่ามีทีวีๆมีทีวี
คิดถึงอะไรครับคิดถึงอะไรนะ
Back  To  The  Future
อ่า
[เพลง]
ที่เป็นในอดีตแล้วก็บิติที่เป็นอนาคต
แต่นี่เป็นมิติที่เราอยู่กับมิติในทีวี
ที่เราดู
อ่า
เมืองรีโมททะลุมิติมหัศจรรย์
เจ้
มหัศจรรย์ก็เหมือนๆกับอะไรนะหาอ่า Harry
Potter ใช่ครับมีพลังมหัศจรรย์
พี่เสกได้มีอะไรที่ไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือน
ปกติ
พิเศษพิเศษนะมหัศจรรย์
ไปครับเหมือนกับอันนี้ไงเรียนภาษาไทยโดย
ไม่ต้องเขียนโง่ได้ครับไม่มีการบ้าน
ดูกับฟังเปล่าวันนักเรียนก็จะพูดได้โดย
อัตโนมัติอ้าว้าวมาสุดยัน
โอเคไปดูหนังดีกว่าค่ะไปดูกันครับอ่ะ
เริ่มเริ่มต้นเริ่มต้นมีผู้ชายคนนี้ครับ
แต่คนนี้ชื่ออะไรเดวิด
David
David  David
เป็น
สำเนียงของคนไทยเรียกเดวิทเลยอ่ะมีชีวิต
เดวิทนะฮะโอเค
เดวิทนี่อายุประมาณเท่าไหร่ค่ะคุณเดวิท
อายุประมาณ 18
18 เป็นวัยรุ่นใช้คำเป็นวัยรุ่นยังเรียน
หนังสืออยู่หรือเรียนหนังสือหรืออยู่ใน
เขาใหญ่อยู่ใต้ครับมอบมัธยมปลายใช่ครับ
อยู่มัธยมมหาวิทยาลัยเนาะมาเด็ก 18 ก็
มัธยมปลายเรียนเสร็จว่าจะไปมหาวิทยาลัย
มหาวิทยาลัยที่อเมริกามีอะไรบ้างอ่ะ
เที่ยวอเมริกาใช่ไหมครับเนี่ยกูไอ้ตี้ไม่
รู้เรียกชื่อถูกหรือเปล่าอาจจะอยู่คนละ
ประเทศนะอ่าแมสซาชูเสทอยู่อเมริกามั้ย
อเมริกา
โอเคแล้วก็ห้องมีอะไรอีก
คนยังเบียร์ใช่มั้ยอ้าโอเค of ก่อนไม่ใช่
เพราะประมาณยังกลัวอยู่อังกฤษใจครับหน้า
ก็มีอะไรอีก 5 ประมาณนั้นประมาณนั้น
ถ้าไทยอ่ะเรารู้
มหาวิทยาลัยที่ไทยเรา
คนนี้ก็อยู่ม.ปลาหมอปลาไร
ปีหน้าก็จะไปมหาวิทยาลัยได้ค่ะแต่คนเนี้ย
เดวิทอ้าเดวิทเนี่ยชอบชอบดูชอบดูทีวี
เหมือนครูเอ๋เลยเอกก็ตอบดูทีวีใช่ไหมดู
ทีวีบางทีทีวีดูคู๋นะฮะหลับ
หน้าทีวีเกิดดูผู้เก๋นอนหลับ
ชีวิตชอบดูทีวีมากเหรอคะใช้ครับชอบดูทีวี
มากแล้วก็เออทีวีตอนนี้ตอนนี้ทีวีนี่เป็น
ทีวีที่เป็นภาพ B  4 สีมีสีใช่มั้ยบ้าน
ครูเอ๋บ้านครัวตี้เวลาเปิดทีวีทีวีขึ้นจะ
มีสีใช่ๆสีสีแล้วนะฮะทีวีก็จะมีสีอ้ะสี
ฟ้าใช่ครับพี่สีเยอะๆเนี่ยเราเราใส่เสื้อ
ก็จะมีสีน้ำเงินก็น่าทรายทรายใคร
background สีเขียวก็เห็นสีเขียวได้ครับ
ทีวีที่เดวิดเขาดูเขาชอบดูรายการนึงมีราย
การที่เป็นทีวีขาวดำ
กับสีดำครับมีสีขาวนี่มีสีขาวกับสีดำ 2
สี
อ่าใช้ครับแล้วเราทำซุงเป็นสีขาวสีดำได้
ไหมสุสู้เป็นศิษย์สีขาวสีดำนะครับหน้ามัน
จะมีอยู่แค่ 2 สีโอเคค่ะอ้ามีสีขาวตรงนี้
แล้วก็สีดำตรงนี้นะแต่ก็ดูรู้เรื่องนั้น
เป็นทีวีสมัยก่อนทีวีสมัยก่อนอ่ะจะเป็นสี
ขาวแล้วก็สีดำ Model  with ช็อปทีวีเขาดำ
ชอบรายการนี้รายการนี้เป็นสีขาวกับสีดำ
ค่ะแต่เดวิทก็มีน้องเดวิทมีน้องด้วยน้อง
ของเดวิฟไม่อยากดูดูที่ดูทีวีแต่ไม่
อยากดูข่าวอะไรการที่มีขาวดำที่มีแค่สอบ
สิไม่อยากดูน้าทั้งคู่ก็เลยแย่งรีโมทกัน
แย่งรีโมทน้องน้องอยากจะดูทีวีวันนี้ฉัน
จะดูทีวีช่องอื่นไปกับไม่ดูช่องนี้แต่พี่
พี่พี่อยากดูช่องช่องขาวดำอารายการหนีก็
เลยแย่งแย่งกันแล้วเดวิดยอมให้น้องดูทีวี
ช่องอื่นไหมคะอ่ะไม่ยอมน้องก็ไม่ยอมเดวิท
ก็ไม่ยอมเป็นพี่
น้องของเดวิสเกิดอะไรขึ้นเกิดอะไรของ
เดวิดชื่อเจนิเฟอร์
แกสองคนแย่งแย่งรีโมทรีโมทกันครับใครชนะ
อ่านแย่งกันจนรีโมทหลุดมือตกไปที่พื้นทาง
อ้าว
ทางรีโมททางขวดแล้วใช่ไหมกดกดไม่ได้ TV
รุ่นนี้กดไม่ได้ต้องใช้รีโมทเข้านั้น
โอ้ยสองคนก็ไม่ได้ดูทีวีสิไม่ได้ดู 5 แต่
ว่าแต่ว่าไม่แฮปปี้เอ็นดิ้งก็ไม่อยากมี
ยังไม่จบกับครึ่งเธอมาเริ่มแล้วโอเคตั้ง
แต่ว่าก็มีช่างซ่อมทีวีมาอ้ะมีทั้งซ่อม
ทีวีมาซ่อมรีโมทให้
อาเราจะไปแล้วค่ะอ่ะไม่ได้โทรช่างมาเอง
มาจากไหนมาจากไหนไม่รู้
Day  with  a  regional  Level กล้อง
ช่างรู้ได้ยังไงว่ารีโมทเสียเดวิดโคเอโย
ตี้ถ้าสมมตริมครู Arty นะตกแล้วก็พังครับ
แล้วติดต้องช่างซ่อมรีโมทกู Arty จะให้
เข้าบ้านไหมอ่ะป่วยที่ก็เออไม่ให้เข้าไม่
ให้เข้าเพราะรู้ได้ยังไงว่ารีโมทเสียยัง
ไม่ได้โทรยังไม่เคยโทรทรายน่าฮ่าน่ากลัว
มากๆเดวิดเดวิดให้เข้ามาแล้วก็ให้ช่างถ้า
มีโหมดเพราะว่าเดวิดอย่างดูทีวีได้ใจกับ
น้าแล้วช่างซ่อมรีโมทก็เอารีโมทแปลกๆเขา
รีโมทแปลกๆมาให้ไม่เหมือนเดิมไม่เหมือน
เดิมนะคะใช่ครับนี่ครับ
แต่
หน้าตาแปลกไม่เหมือนรีโมททำมันใหญ่ๆกว่า
เดิมใช่ครับใหญ่กว่าเดิมเออ
โอเคอะแล้วอ่าตอนนี้ถ้ารับมาแล้วก็มันก็
กลับมาจะดูทีวีต่อน้าจะดูทีวีต่อแต่ตอน
นี้พอช่างกลับไปแล้วช่างให้รีโมทไว้ทั้ง
สองคนเดวิสคัพเจนิเฟอร์แย่งรีโมทกันอีก
อ๋อโอ้ยพ่อแม่อยู่ไหนเนี่ยพ่อแม่ไม่อยู่
บ้านอ่า
ทั้งคู่ก็แย่งรีโมทกันอีกอ่ะขายรีโมทอัน
นี้ไม่ใช่รีโมทธรรมดา
ห่าไม่ธรรมดาแย่งกันไปแย่งกันมาพอดีไปโดน
ปุ่มบนรีโมทเป็นปุ่มนะผมนะคะอันนี้รีโมท
แอร์นะครับดูกันไปโดนปุ่มบริบทแล้วทีวี
ทีวีก็สู้ทั้งสองคนเข้าไปในทีวี
หาน้าใส่ครับ
คือปรากฏว่ารีโมทไปกดปุ่มอะไรไม่รู้ใช่คน
ปุ่มอะไรไม่รู้วันนี้ดูจะคุยแล้วเขาทิ้ง
เอาไปไหนทีวี
ป้าก็หายไปเลยหายเข้าไปในทีวีนะครับเข้า
ไปในทีวีที่เป็นทีวีขาวดำ
เอ้าหรอคะนี่ทั้งสองคนเดวิสกับ Jennifer
เข้ามาอยู่ในทีวีก็กลายเป็นสีขาว
มีสีดำสีดำไม่มี
เอากลับไปดูภาพเดิมก่อนได้ไหมคะอาหาร
ผมของ Jennifer กับผมเดวิทแล้วก็แฟชั่น
ดูภาพกลับไปค่ะข่าว
มันเปลี่ยนไปอ่ะเหมือนไหมอ๋อ
อ้าวไปขายกันแต่บ้านนี้เขาอาจจะหันหัน
หน้าไปคนละด้านกันนะแต่เป็นคนละคนกันเฮ้ย
คือรู้สึกว่าเสื้อเขาเปลี่ยนวงเวียนเข้า
ไปในทีวีแล้วก็เปลี่ยนนะฮะให้ครับเปลี่ยน
เป็นตัวเขาอันนี้เป็นรายการในทีวีปกติอะ
ทีวีดูดเขาเข้าไปก็กลายเป็นเดวิทไปอยู่ใน
นั้นกลายเป็น Jennifer ไปอยู่นี้แทนแทน
ดาราให้แทนดาราสองคนที่อยู่ในทีวีนะก็หาย
ไป David กับไจเปอร์เข้าไปแทน
นะอีกคนนึงคือใครเหมือนช่างซ่อมรีโมทอ่ะ
คนนี้เป็นพ่อของข้อของเดวิดหน้ากับ
Jennifer อ่า
ในทีวีไทย tv ได้ครับในทีวีเขาไปแทนดารา
ในทีวี Eyes  I แถวมานี่เดวิดยังถือรีโมท
เขาจำได้ครับจำได้แล้วเขาก็จำเรื่องใน
ทีวีได้เพราะว่าเดวิดเคยดูเคยดูเรื่องนี้
ในทีวีแล้วเดวิดก็เลย 5 รู้จักหน้าคนนี้
เป็นพ่อค่ะเออใจครับ
จะมีเฟอร์ไม่เคยดูไม่เคยดูรายการนี้จะมี
เฟอร์ไม่รู้ค่ะไม่รู้ก็คุยกับพี่ถามพี่
ว่าคืออะไรใครไปคือพ่อใครคือแม่ใครคือมี
เพื่อนชายทำไมฉันอยู่ที่นี่
ก็ส่งทำไมฉันสีดำอะไรอ่ะใช่ครับเพราะทุก
คนก็มีแต่สีขาวสีดำยังไม่มีสีในเค้าจะมี
เพื่อนตกใจไหมอาจจะมี First ตาตกใจมันจะ
with ล่ะคะเดวิทก็ได้บีก็ตกใจที่ตัวเอง
เข้ามาอยู่ที่นี่ได้ยังไงแต่ก็จากดีใจไป
ไม่ได้ไม่รู้ว่าจะกลับออกไปข้างนอกยังไง
ใช่ครับ
แล้วก็ทำยังไงต่อคะเขาก็ต้องใช้ชีวิตอยู่
ในนั้นก็ไปโรงเรียนปกตินะครับพรุ่งนี้ก็
ไปโรงเรียน
เวลาที่ไปโรงเรียนเจนนิเฟอร์ก็ถามถาม
เพื่อนๆถามคุณครูเพื่อนๆก็จะไม่รู้เรื่อง
ไม่รู้เรื่องเพราะว่าอายในทีวีก็มีเรื่อง
แค่ในถ้ามีจะไม่รู้เรื่องนอกนอกค่ะน้องรส
ๆมามันเหมือนเป็นสคริปต์ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
นี่ดาราต้องพูดๆๆเปิดขามไม่รู้ในสคริปต์ 5
ไม่ได้ถามในสคริปต์
ทุกคนไม่รู้จักถามอะไรถามอะไรอ่ะได้ครับ
หน้าคูกล้องงงอ่า Jennifer ก็ถามเยอะเลย
อ่าใช่ครับก็ชอบถามฮ่าๆๆเดี๋ยวนี้เฟอร์
อยากรู้อาญาแกรู้หลายๆเรื่องนะครับแล้ว
มันเกิดอะไรขึ้นเองอีกแล้วก็ตัวเดวิด
เดวิดเขาตอนที่กลางวันเขาไปเรียนตอนเย็น
หลังเลิกเรียนก็ไปทำงานที่ร้านอาหารด้วย
ค่ะอ้าไปทำงานที่ร้านอาหารก็อันนี้เป็น
เอ่อเสียวของร้านอาหารใช่ครับที่เดวิดทำ
งานด้วยค่ะนะครับซึ่งเจ้าของร้านอาหารนี้
ก็เออรับบทเป็นอ่าคนขายอาหารที่มีเดวิดมา
ช่วยทำอาหารค่ะแต่เวลาที่เดวิดไม่มาคนขาย
อาหารก็ไม่มีบท
ไม่มีบทไม่มีสคริป
เขาคลิปเองไม่ได้เขาก็ทำงานแค่ strip ที่
เขาทำก็คือให้เดวิดมาช่วยแล้วขายอาหารคอ
ได้ with ไม่อยู่เขาก็ขายไม่ได้
แต่ตอนนี้เดวิดไม่ใช่เดวิดคนเดิมเป็น
เดวิดคนที่มาจากโลกข้างนอกค่ะ
บอกว่า
แสดงว่าในทีวี
ดาราผู้ชายก็ซื้อเดวิทเหมือนกันอ่า
คนละชื่อครับแต่ว่าผมเรียกว่า Day
วิเคราะห์นักเรียนจะได้ไม่งงอ่ะคู๋จะได้
ไม่งง
ดาราคนนี้ไปแทนดาราตอนนี้ใครไม่ได้ปีหน้า
ก็ขายอาหารไม่ได้ๆครับเฮ้ยแล้วครับพอพอดี
บิดเข้าไปแทนผู้ชายคนเนี้ยแล้วเวลาเข้าไป
ที่ร้านอาหารขายดอกมั้ยคะขายได้เดวิดก็
เลยสอนให้ให้คนนี้ทำทุกอย่างทำเองขายเอง
ไม่ต้องรอเดวิดใช่ถ่ายเพราะว่าเขาพูดไม่
เก่งอ่าให้ครับอ่าแต่ตอนนี้เดวิดก็บอก
เดวิทก็สอนทำแบบนี้ทำแบบนี้ทำได้เลยคิด
เองทำเองได้เลยไม่ต้องรอเขาไม่ต้องรอ
devitt
ในกับเทคนิคการทำอาหารงานขายได้ครับแล้ว
ก็อ่าน้องสาวน้องสาวชอบน้องสาวก็ไปไปเจอ
ผู้ชายที่อยู่ในห้องเดียวกันอ้ะต้องชอบ
กันอ่ะใช่ครับมีแฟนในเรื่องนี้นะครับ
เพราะชอบกัน We  are  a เจนิเฟอร์ก็ทำให้
ผู้ชายคนนี้มาชอบของ Jennifer ทำให้อ่า
เขามองเห็นผู้ชายคนนี้ก็มีความรักมีความ
รักนั้นกลับจะมีเกิดก็เลยมองเห็นมองเห็น
ดอกไม้เป็นสีแดง
รอบอ่ะตอนนี้เริ่มมี 4 และเริ่มมี 4 นะ
คือหนึ่งเข้าดำเปลี่ยนเป็นสีแดงเพราะว่า
มีความรักรั่ว Multi หน้าใจครับเพิ่มดีดู
หนังโรแมนติกนะคะ
นี่ดู Honey บาวนะคะดีบาวนี่เออเป็นหนัง
โคตรใช่ไหมครับอ่าโอเค
5 เสร็จแล้วก็เดี๋ยวมีความรักกันเพื่อนๆ
ก็เห็น
หน้าพ่อไปที่โรงเรียนหลายๆคนเพื่อนของ
Jennifer ก็เริ่มเริ่มที่จะหากคุยกัน
แล้วก็รักกันก็เริ่มมีคนที่ก็มีสีเข้ามา
ในในเมืองนิ
ผู้หญิงคนนี้อะอะไรนะเพื่อน
เขาทำอะไรใช่ไหมครับฝรั่งใช่ไหมหาใช่ครับ
หมากฝรั่งเปล่ากำลังออกมาหาเป่าเป็นสี
ชมพูใช้ครับ R เมืองนี้เมืองที่เขาเข้าไป
นี้ก็เริ่มเริ่มมีสี
เริ่มมีสีสีขาวกับสีดำ 2 สีชายขับไม้สี
แดงไงครับหมากฝรั่ง
ชาย
5 มีอยู่วันนึงมีอยู่วันหนึ่งเกิดไฟไหม้
ครับ
ไปไม่ที่ต้นไม้นะอ่าไปก็เป็นสีด้วยไปก็
เป็นสีครับน่าจะสีขาวใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับปกติ
ก็จะเป็นสีขาวเป็นควันเดี๋ยวนี้สีขาวๆแบบ
นี้แต่คราวนี้เริ่มมีสีเข้ามาในเมืองแค่
นี้แหละน่าในเมืองนี้เริ่มมี 4 แล้วนะ
ครับไม่ที่ไหนโรงเรียนไม่ที่ต้นไม้ที่
บ้านครับง้อที่บ้านอ่าแต่เดวิดเดวิดก็ไป
เรียกช่างดับเพลิงมาอ้ะมีพนักงานดับเพลิง
มาถึงตอนแรกพนักงานดับเพลิงยังใช้เครื่อง
ดับเพลิงไหม้เป็นเพราะว่าในเมืองนี้ใน
เมืองนี้ยังไม่เคยมีไฟไหม้ในหนังเรื่อง
นี้ยังไม่เคยมีไฟไหม้ช่างดับเพลิงก็ไม่
รู้ว่าต้องทำยังไงเดวิทก็เลยต้องไปสอนไป
สอนช่างดับเพลิงให้ดับเพลิง
ช่างดับเพลิงก็เลยใช้เครื่องดับเพลิงแล้ว
ก็สามารถดับตื่นได้ดับไฟที่ไม่ได้ไปนะ
อะไรครับถ้าเป็นประเทศไทยเราเรียกตำรวจ
เนาะเป็นตำรวจดับเพลิงใช่ไหมประเทศไทยนะ
คะเป็นตำรวจดับเพลิงนะ
ปัดประเทศนักเรียนอาจจะไม่ใช่ตำรวจอ่ะ
เนาะเป็นช่างเป็นพนักงานพนักงานอ่า
พนักงานดับเพลิงตะเคจะกลับ
ไปเดวิด
ต้องมีแฟนเหมือนกันเดวิดก็มีแฟนเหมือนกัน
น่ะเดวิทก็มีความรักกับผู้หญิงอีกคนนึง
อ่านแล้วจากนั้นในเมืองนี้ก็เริ่มเริ่มมี
สีขึ้นมา
ทุกคนต่างก็เริ่มมีความรักเริ่มคุยกัน
เริ่มอ่าก็เลยมีสีเพราะว่าทุกคนมีอารมณ์
มีอารมณ์ที่แตกต่างไปจากเดิมหรือชายและสี
ก็เริ่มแล้วก่อนกูเอาตีบอกมีอารมณ์ที่
เปลี่ยนใช่ครับเปลี่ยน
อาหารก็มีความสุขขึ้นใช่ครับเป็นอารมณ์
ที่อาจจะเป็นมีความสุขมีความเศร้าดีใจ
เสียใจเพราะว่าก่อนหน้าที่เดวิทกับจะมี
เพื่อจะเข้ามาในเมืองนี้เมืองนี้จะมีแต่
วันศุกร์เป็นเมืองแสนสุข
ให้ไม่มีเรื่องไม่ดีไม่มีไฟไหม้ทุกคนไม่
รู้จักไฟไหม้ทุกคนไม่รู้จักโกรธทุกคนรู้
จักแต่ยิ้มมีความสุข
จริงๆก็ดีแล้วใช่ไหมงั้นเดวิดเข้าไปทำให้
ไม่ดีเหรอคะเนี่ยอ้าๆใช่ครับเด็กที่เข้า
ไปแล้วทำให้ทุกคนเกิดความรู้สึกอย่างอื่น
ด้วยอ่าเจอความรู้สึกชอบไม่ชอบโกรธดีใจ
เสียใจได้กับก็เลยทำให้เกิด 4 สารต่างๆ
ออนมันแต่เมื่อก่อนนี้ก็จะมีความสุขอย่าง
เดียว
เรียบความสุขอย่างเดียวสๆไม่มีสีสันใต้
ไม่มีสีสัตเออ
แล้วก็ครับถ้าวันนึงถ้าอยู่มาวันนึงอ่ะ
เทศบาลเมืองอันนี้อาจไม่ใช่เทศบาลเอ่อคน
นี้นี้คนที่ดูแลเมืองนะครับคนที่คอยมาดู
แลเมืองเรียกว่า
อา
ก็เทศบาลเทศบาลไหมฮ่าๆอ่ะอาจจะเรียกว่า
อ่าเดี๋ยวเรียกว่าในอำเภออยากว่าว่า
ราชการผู้ว่าผู้ว่าโอเคกูว่า
กูว่าก็เริ่มเห็นว่าเอ๊ยเมืองนี้แตกต่าง
ไปจากเดิม
แตกต่างไปจากเดิมทำให้คนบางคนดีใจเสียใจ
ร้องให้ผู้ว่าก็ไม่ชอบผู้ว่าก็เลยตั้งกฎ
ว่าต่อไปห้ามห้ามให้ต่อทุกคนมีสี
ไม่มีสีห้ามไม่ให้อ่ะแตกต่างไปจากเดิมให้
ไปให้กลับมามีความสุขเหมือนเดิมใช่ครับ
ให้มีแต่สีขาวสีดำแต่แต่เดวิดเดวิดก็ไม่
เชื่อใน with ก็น่าเชื่อทรายหาผู้ว่า
ต้องการให้เป็นสีเดิมได้หากว่าต้องการให้
กลับมาเป็นสีขาวสีดำเหมือนเดิมรักเขา
ทะเลาะกับเดวิดไม่ได้ใช่ครับทะเลาะกับ
เดวิดเดวิดไม่ไม่ชอบอะเดวิเดวิดไม่เชื่อ
ใช่ครับเพราะ
ว่าจะทำได้อ่าไม่เชื่อว่าทุกคนควรจะมีแต่
ความสุขอย่างเดียวไม่เชื่อว่าทุกคนจะทำ
เหมือนเดิมอ่าไปทำงานเหมือนเดิมไปโรง
เรียนเหมือนเดิมคิดเหมือนเดิมพูดเหมือน
เดิมผู้สคริปต์เดิมอยู่ในเรื่องเดิมทราย
นิดไม่ชอบอ่ะก็เลยน่ะถูกจับไปนะครับตอน
นี้ก็แบ่งพวกกันพวกที่มีสีก็คือชอบแบบที่
เดวิดทำกับขวดที่ไม่ชอบแบบที่เดวิดทำก็
แบ่งโซน c  l สีดำไก่ใช่ครับแล้วก็ทะเลาะ
กันทะเลาะกันนะครับและสุดท้ายสุดท้าย
เดวิดเดวิดกอล์ฟคุยกับผู้ว่าผู้ว่าก็
เริ่มเริ่มโกรธไปโกรธเขาผู้ว่าโกรธกูข้าง
เลยมีสี
สันหน้าวีสีเลยเพราะผู้ว่าไม่ได้มีความ
สุขอย่างเดียวเหมือนเดิมแล้วผู้ว่าโกรธ
โคตรผู้ว่าก็มีสี 5 ว่าตกใจไว้ให้พวกตกใจ
นะครับแล้วคนอื่นๆก็เริ่มเริ่มมีอาร์หา
ใช่ครับก็เริ่มมีสีจากนั้นทั้งเมืองก็มี
สีมีสีสันในทั้งเมืองก็กลับมามีสีสัน
เหมือนเดิมเมื่อทั้งดูแล้วตอนนี้ได้ครับ
ตอนนี้ไม่โกรธแล้วหรอผู้ว่าน่าใจแล้วก็ไป
ฮ่าๆๆผู้ว่าก็ชอบแล้วที่ตอนนี้ตัวเองมี
ความรู้สึกเปลี่ยนไปไม่เหมือนเดิมแล้วน่า
ใช่ครับไม่มันไม่เฉยมันแบบเกือบคนนะมัน
เตือนพรุ่งนี้เหมือนกับจะบอกว่าคนเนี่ยจะ
ต้องแบบก็จะมีใจมากอ่ามีเสียใจด้วยอ่ะมี
ชอบดูบ่อยมีไม่ชอบด้วยอันนี้เป็นธรรมดา
ใช่ไหมธรรมดาได้ใจก่อนคุณนิ่งอันเนี้ยไม่
ธรรมดาใช่ไหมคะ
งั้นถ้าคุณรู้สึกโกรธก็ไม่ต้องเสียใจไป
ทำไมถึงโกรธโกรธไปแล้วก็อ้าธรรมดาอาใช่
เขา
แต่ว่าดีใจเสร็จแล้วก็ธรรมดา
ร้องไห้ๆก็เป็นธรรมดาทดลองให้ได้ดีใจได้
เสียใจได้หืออันนี้เป็นคนใช่ไหม Sleep
สันของชีวิตอยู่ Witch ได้ครับอารมณ์ก็
เป็นสีสันของชีวิตน่ะแต่แก๊ปต้องมีอารมณ์
หลายๆอารมณ์ 5 เหมือนกับที่ต้องมีสีมี
หลายๆสีเหมือนกันเออเงื่อเพลงอันนี้จบโดย
ที่ 2 จบแล้วหรอคะอ่ะจบแล้วครับตอนจบก็
เดี๋ยวสองคนอยู่ในกฏตลอดชีวิตหรอกินข้าว
รีโมทกลับมาเอารีโมตกลับมาแล้วหาทางกด
รีโมทแล้วกลับออกมาอยู่ข้างนอก
ได้ครับตกใจนึกว่าเดวิดกับ Jennifer จะ
ต้องอยู่ในทีวีตลอดชีวิตไม่ไม่ได้อยู่ตอน
จบก็เอารีโมทอันนั้นกลับมากดไม่ครับแล้ว
ก็ออกมาข้างนอกแต่เมืองนี้เออหนังเรื่อง
นี้ที่เขาดูก็เป็น
เป็นสีแล้วอ่าไม่กลับมาเป็นสีขาวดำแล้วก็
ไม่เป็นขาวดำแล้วนายใจกลับ
แล้วเขาก็ออกมาแล้วทีวีเขายังแย่งรีโมท
กับน้องไหมเนี่ยอ้าเขาก็ดีกันแล้วครับไม่
แย่งไม่แห้งรีโมทแล้วครับอ่าดูบอลโลกของ
เดวิดก็เปลี่ยนไปจากสีขาวกับสีดำ
ทีวีกลายเป็นทีวีสีชายครับหน่อยกลายเป็น
ทีวีสีปกติ
คูเอกต้องไปดูและครูอยากรู้มิดอะไรเคยคุย
อยากรู้ว่ามีอะไรซ่อนอยู่อีก
ไม่มีที่ครัวตี้ไม่ได้เล่าอยู่อีกใจกับ
มันกันเล่าไม่หมดในวันนี้ก็ถ้านักเรียน
หรือผู้เก๋อยากรู้อยากรู้ก็ไปดูไปดูจะไป
ดูเพราะครูเอ๋อยากดูอ่ะอยากดูเองนะเข้าใจ
ใหม ending ที่ 2 ของเรื่องนี้ที่ซ่อนเอา
ไว้
เพราะว่าหนังหลายๆเรื่องมีอะไรซ่อนนะคะ
ซ่อนซ่อนก็คือเราต้องคิดดูแล้วก็คิดอะไร
เฮ้ยก็จะเห็นว่ามีอะไรอยู่นะครับพลัง
เรื่องนี้ให้ดูชื่ออีกทีนึงนะครับ wrestle
555 สุดท้ายชื่ออะไรน่ะ
รีโมทรีโมททะลุรีโมทคนทะลุมิติปิดมะหัดสะ
รันแย่ใช้ครับอ่าโทษทะลุมิติมหัศจรรย์นะ
คะภาษาไทยนะภาษาไทย
แต่ถ้าหาภาษาไทยอาจจะหาหาหายากหายากนิด
นึงถ้าหาภาษาอังกฤษหาง่าย views  Are  OK
rn1 ที่ดีขอบคุณครู Arty ค่ะที่ทำให้กู
เอหรือรู้จักหนังเรื่องนี้เก็บตัวเอกจะ
ไม่หามาดูน่าได้ครับนั่งคิดว่าจะจะต้องดู
ว่าคิดว่าจะต้องดู
ได้ครับถ้าชอบก็ชอบหนังแบบนี้อ่าชอบคลิป
แบบนี้นะครับกดไลค์กด Subscribe ในช่อง
คอมรนด์คอมเม้นท์บอกว่ากูอัดดีคู๋ให้ครู 2
คนเล่าเรื่องหนังถ้าขอได้เลยครับแนะนำ
อยากฟังเรื่องอะไรอยากให้ครู Arty อยาก
ให้ครูพี่เอ๋เล่าเรื่องอะไรบอกมาใน
คอมเม้นต์ได้นะครับอะไรนะคะก็ขอบคุณมาก
ค่ะครูเอาตี้ขาอ่าเจอกัน
คลิปหน้านะครับผมไม่รู้
กว่าตีเล่าเขาเองจะบนฝั่งเป็นเพื่อนนัก
เรียนโอเค 5 ดีเค้าอ้าวเออโอเคงั้นคลิป
นี้หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วครับผมเดี๋ยว
ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วครับถ้านะคะนักเรียนอย่า
ลืมนะคะเอาเป็นข้างล่างอยากฟังเรื่องอะไร
แล้วก็คอมเม้นข้างล่างอ่ะอยากฟังอีกฮ่าๆ
เป็นข้างล่างไปครับตอนนี้เราสองคนเข้าไป
แล้วนะนะครับผมลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับพี่
เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะ coati นักเรียนบ๊ายบายน